from software's games have always made
you feel small in many ways they tell
you that you're worthless a plague
ridden rap or accursed undead unfit even
to be cinders they ask you to navigate
unflinching brutal worlds and pit you
against enemies that systematically
dismantle your ego elden ring maintains
the nail bite in combat an era of
mystery that has distinguished from
software soulsborne games but it's
elevated to new heights by the studio's
interpretation of what an open world
game can be having brought down the
first elden lord godric the breadth of
the world and the way in which from
software has applied its signature style
to an open world was on full display
reinforcing how insignificant i really
was and driving home the magnitude of
the tasks that still awaited me
standing on the edge of the cliffside in
leonia of the lakes the area beyond
godric's arena i took in the world laid
out in front of me the enormous urge
tree casting brilliant golden beams of
light onto the land that exists in its
shadow the sharp peaks of a distant
mountain that looked like claws tearing
at the sky a castle standing proudly
amidst ruins a forest blanketed in an
ominous fog it was all overwhelming and
none of the hardships i'd experienced in
demon souls dark souls bloodborne or
sakura have come close to making me feel
as small at the same time i was overcome
with excitement for what the lands
between had in store for me and all the
seemingly insurmountable battles
awaiting and it did not disappoint elden
ring is from software's crowning
achievement in world design epic in
scale and scope but what makes it
special isn't just how visually stunning
it all is or that its open world is vast
rich in detail and teeming with
possibilities instead it's how the
studio has applied its own esoteric
design principles to deliver an
experience that feels fresh elegant and
uniquely from software the game's core
pillars are built on the same strong
action and role-playing foundations as
previous titles while offering more
freedom to explore than ever before
eldon ring is an open world game
entirely in a category of its own that
delicate orchestration of highs and lows
and the build up and release of tension
that from software has mastered coupled
with the thrill of freeform exploration
and discovery is an intoxicating
cocktail of game design a key part of
from software's design ethos is to strip
down to the essentials and in elden ring
that process strengthens exploration and
discovery the heart and soul of the
experience the studios games typically
give the player very little while asking
a lot an elden ring is the most obtuse
and demanding of his game so far this is
largely because everything you've come
to expect from modern day open world
games is absent for instance there's no
map until you find an item that reveals
the topography of a region even then the
points of interest in that region aren't
marked until you've been there and seen
them there is no mini-map just a compass
that shows the cardinal directions and
any waypoints you've placed areas you go
to won't be gated depending on your
level there's no clear indication on
when you should go to key locations the
best you get is at the sights of grace
which function as rest points in the
same way that bonfires lanterns or idols
did in other titles at each of these
sites is a dim trail of golden light
pointing in the general direction of
something perhaps it's the next
milestone on your quest or maybe it's
just another area that has a dungeon the
only way to find out is to make the
journey the challenge for from software
lies in the friction between the
studio's design hallmarks and the
expected conventions of a genre filled
with games that try to be all things to
everyone and although the execution is
an unmitigated success one thing's for
sure eldon ring is not a smooth edged
one-size-fits-all kind of experience
that will accommodate everyone instead
it's unrelentingly opaque relishes in
the savagery of confronting players with
unfavorable odds and delights in
watching the ensuing struggle elden
ring's gameplay will feel familiar to
those with experience of previous from
software games the tried and true
formula of measured third person combat
against enemies that are swift to punish
full hardiness is both as thrilling and
as nerve-wracking as ever from software
has added some new gameplay wrinkles to
its soulsborne formula this time most
notable is a jump which has been pulled
out from the more dynamic movement style
of sakura this is useful not just for
traversal but also for performing a
leaping strike that can break through an
enemy's defense and create a critical
strike opportunity another new mechanic
is the ability to strike back after
blocking an enemy's attack with a heavy
counter dealing a good amount of damage
the heavy counter has some of the
satisfaction of bloodborne's gunshot and
visceral combo though it's not as
gratifyingly dramatic while it's easy to
rely on it a great deal of strategy is
still needed to perfectly execute it as
an enemy's quick follow-up strike could
cut you down before you've initiated the
counter the new gameplay mechanics
certainly provide more options against
tough foes but they still require the
player to know their opponent and
carefully select their moments the last
major addition is spirit ashes which
allow the player to summon upgradeable
ai controlled fighters to their side of
course there are restrictions around
summoning them as spirit ashes can only
be used in specific locations and only
once per life they're also susceptible
to being killed by more powerful enemies
making them better equipped for pulling
aggro than securing victories these kind
of thoughtful tweaks extend to the
checkpointing system which is a little
more lenient to accommodate the open
nature of the game instead of being
returned to a site of grace when killed
the open world is littered with small
statues called stakes of marika these
can usually be found around particularly
challenging areas whether that's because
there's a group of enemies in a
fortified location or a singular
mini-boss that must be faced in one of
the many heart-pounding soul-crushing
and utterly confidence-destroying
encounters this addition is more of a
necessity for taking out the
frustrations of having to travel large
distances in an open world the
challenges the stakes of america precede
are no less forgiving elden ring is
undoubtedly difficult much harder than
any of from software's previous games
and while a great deal of that is owed
to the challenging bosses and enemies a
significant amount is also because of
the freedom the game offers the player
it doesn't tell you where to go in any
way so it can be very easy to find
yourself in places that are too
difficult for you to navigate instead it
just trusts you to assess the situation
and consider your own capabilities both
as a player and a character then decide
if you should return to a place that is
more manageable and continue building
your character up to come back later
some like me will fall hopelessly in
love with the thrill of blindly
wandering into a corner of the map and
being ruthlessly murdered for hours on
end just to walk away with little more
than the satisfaction that i kept
picking myself up and eventually emerged
victorious albeit battered and bruised
others however will find the idea of
navigating a perilous catacomb down to
its deepest depth while braving all
manner of horrifying creatures just for
a few measly crafting materials to be
the epitome of unrewarding but either
way there's a boldness to the approach
that deserves to be respected the lands
between is no less content rich than
many of its open world contemporaries
and it offers much to do in fact it's an
immensely large game that is bursting
with activities to undertake in the
starting area of limb grave alone there
are numerous caves tunnels ruins
catacombs shacks and encampments to find
these may not always lead to meaningful
progress in becoming an elder lord or
advancing a key questline but none of it
felt superfluous or boring this is
because what these activities offer is
far more meaningful a gameplay loop that
sparks a curiosity to uncover the
secrets that the lands between hold and
the raw satisfaction of discovery
discovering things to do is as intensely
satisfying as doing them and that is
what eldon ring is predicated upon the
same sense of growth and satisfaction
that comes from conquering lordran or
becoming completely at home in yharnam
is present as you brave the lands
between but once struck fear into your
heart becomes trivial as you venture
deeper and spend ruins to level up and
grow stronger it shouldn't come as a
surprise that a from software game isn't
quick to dish out rewards and praise for
tasks you undertake instead the most
valuable rewards are intangible and
internal a sense of personal growth that
comes from your mastery of mechanics and
domination of the world's vicious
denizens or the feeling of journeying
through this inhospitable land as a
cartographer poking into its various
nooks and crannies and seeing what lurks
there there are countless moments that
will catch you off guard and fuel that
desire to explore on one occasion i
traveled to a remote shack where a war
master had taken up residence he had
always been there but this was my first
time visiting at night and he wasn't in
the shack when i approached it a cloud
of red appeared and from within a night
menacingly stepped out to do battle it
proceeded to wipe the floor with me but
considering it was telekinetically
wielding a large spectral blade i'd say
it had a bit of an advantage this was
one of many moments just like it that
made my mind race with possibilities
with the world as vast as the land
betweens that shifts dramatically
depending on the time of day what else
was out there for me to see elden ring
is a game where the possibilities feel
endless and i felt driven to chase them
all down as each one offers a memorable
moment and made the world feel richer
freeform exploration isn't completely
new and the proverbial elephant in the
room in that regard is the legend of
zelda breath of the wild it's easy to
draw comparisons between elder ring and
nintendo's acclaimed open world zelda
but what sets the two apart is a greater
sense of authorship around the things
that you can stumble upon in the lands
between and an overall cohesion between
the open world and these activities
elden ring is seamless whether you're
delving into a cliffside cave or
breaching a massive castle front and in
spite of the vast diversity amongst
these locations although there are
occasional breaks to make a transition
these are just for a few specific
set-piece locations that are elaborate
dungeons with ambitious design ideas
think of it as going from hemwick
channel lane to cainhurst castle in
bloodborne while the open world
represents a newer soulsborne gameplay
experience that prioritizes freedom and
player agency there are also numerous
key locations that are more in line with
the enclosed directed areas of previous
games stormville castle redmayne castle
and rio lucaria among others are where
from software continues to do what it
does best create visually arresting
locations that are intricately designed
to loop and weave in on themselves in a
way that makes navigating through them
as joyous as it is perilous each of the
key locations in the game has a distinct
atmosphere aesthetic and vibe and i
found it impossible not to marvel at the
craftsmanship on show this is the kind
of game where you have to stop to see
the sights even when the sights are
grotesque creatures that make you worry
about the minds that created them there
are areas of elder rings world that feel
as genuinely terrifying as bloodborne
like caled where the river runs the
color of copper fissures erupt like
bursting arteries trees are shriveled
and curled like the hands of an ancient
witch and the blood red sky stretches as
far as the eye can see but hop on
torrent your spectral steed and ride
west to limgrave and you'll realize that
the lands between isn't entirely a world
on the brink of collapse with life about
to be snuffed out it's very much alive
and that much is evident from the
verdant fields bustling wildlife and
picturesque vistas if you're in the
right place at the right time you might
even find yourself in a moment of
serenity as the light of morning dawn
sweeps over a forest and trees gently
sway in the wind the most impressive
part of it all is how it coalesces in a
single landmass that the player can
travel across despite the fact that each
area looks and feels like it could be
from an entirely different game needless
to say elden ring is a gorgeous game and
a spectacular feast for the eyes much
has been made of george r.r martin's
involvement but there's little in elden
ring that stands out as having his
fingerprints on it from the characters
to the narrative and the way it's
delivered in broken pieces for the
player to fill the gaps in it's
unmistakably hidataka miyazaki and the
from software team and it's all
fascinating to talk about it would be to
deprive you and the largest soulsborne
community of one of the greatest joys of
a new from software game so i won't do
that but it's safe to say that the
expansive world which george rr martin
have laid the foundation for is filled
with memorable characters some have
mysterious motivations while others have
tragic fates and somber backstories
there's clashing ideologies divine
entities and clandestine groups vying
for power all the pieces and item
descriptions needed to supercharge the
from software law video industrial
complex are there i have just a small
grasp of everything going on and i
cannot wait for the larger community to
get involved so we can all piece it
together as a collective elden ring is a
game that i firmly believe was designed
to be a communal experience not because
it has online co-op but because there
are so many things in the game to
discover that it will undoubtedly
encourage speaking feverishly into the
wee hours of things seen and places
discovered the community that has
already emerged around the game reminds
me of when demon souls was first
released and players took to forums to
share their experiences and guide each
other through the game that kind of
galvanization around the game is truly
special and only possible here because
of from software's decision to pull back
on what it tells the player while
trusting that they will find their own
sense of adventure chase their
curiosities and engage in jolly
cooperation in a genre that's become
wrought with bloated and over-designed
games eldon ring is defiantly contrarian
in almost every way its commitment to
design by subtraction and to placing the
responsibility of charting a path
through its world entirely on the player
makes it stand head and shoulders above
other open world titles elden ring takes
the shards of what came before and
forges them into something that will go
down in history as one of the all-time
greats
a triumph in design and creativity and
an open world game that distinguishes
itself for what it doesn't do as much as
what it does
you